that's the reason why he's in this
league and in fact he was sensational in
Game five as was Taranto at 45 points
and quickly knocks down his first shot
becomes shaman drives blocked by
draymond Green great hustle to get back
defensively there ant i'ma pull up
snails ooh block there in the Durant
none of the best in the league allowing
the to demand blocked by Thompson the
demand with Lou Williams and Harrell
coming into the game and Durant racing
down a floor on another pretty feed from
draymond Green
Golden State when they turn up to deep
ends they're pretty good she with a good
offensive move they send a tag and
transitions pretty good flickers still
for the four-point lead at 26 points and
started slowly in that game as Durant
drives gets inside thanks to a Euro step
that's just unguardable and that's not
just a problem for this game
that's a problems for the next series as
Durant finishes another one poor
transition defense that time by the
Clippers Durant off to a great start
he's got 12 points Durant
I'm a pull-up after Kevin Durant 15
points already here in the first quarter
Chick Beverly and every other defendant
in this league there's nothing you could
do to defend this guy is on his terms
did you walk out of the bank before
finishing your banking needs yes Wow
temple is guarding Durant right now
[Applause]
their aunt turns BIOS counting on one
Devon Durant with a hand that his face
with a chance for a three-point play
clock winding down turn temple tries to
contestant temple trying to stay William
Durant again same splat pull-up same
result bought of his head hair at
temples doing this job this is Stella
defense but give me great offense over
great defense any day of the week Kevin
Durant getting in his spot they Godiva
there's Livingston nice feedback kick it
out open Durant that's good a
two-pointer for Durant
well good extra pass Saints Livingston's
egg with dolla such a rant and draymond
Green finds Durant Durant straight on
three it's good Kevin Durant 28 points
already and there's still seven on a
half to go here in the second the best
player
the Warriors do a great job of what a
guy has it going Durant find some room
but sit in Kevin Durant 31 points
[Applause]
yeah Nazareth education but you're right
good opportunity for Durant go two for
one try to get a quick shot up Iran does
three-pointer bang Kevin Durant's got 36
and the lead balloons to 19 free throws
you knew it was coming
gets a three-point line